do you really think it's that you're not
smart enough or that you're just turned
off by social media says that your
difference weren't enough to figure it
out but maybe it's just it seems more
notes yeah I'm not genuine and it's no
there's yeah there's you know self
promotions a tough a tough thing and it
is this about self-promotion and in
there is a certain aspect that I do
believe you know you have to distance
yourself from a lot of that to create
something good you know that that they
can be really difficult to do those at
the same time you know I mean it's
probably ideal debt that there's
somebody who really enjoys it as good at
the social media stuff and they handle
it for a production and you know I mean
that's probably the way I would hope to
do it you know in the futures use people
who who really enjoy it and kind of know
what they're doing more cuz I mean
that's part of it is you know certainly
yeah you can look at how other movies
have succeeded or not with with using it
in the past and hope to emulate yeah I
don't I don't know if I'm if I'm
completely you know getting at the right
point with it of look how one would you
wouldnt to use it yeah I don't know do
you think will rebel against social
media as a society and soon I don't know
they'll be parts that that too but
hinano be people who are successful
because they have rebelled and gone you
know completely away from it and and
then the be people emulate them and you
know I think it's a lot of is probably
that the balance hasn't been found in it
yet because the thing these things come
up so fast and that's also new new new
and good and good and good that you know
we're not given the time to see that
it's always about a balance of using it
and not using it just like any of these
you know new technologies that that come
along
you